the movie begins with a commercial from
lunar Industries in the late 21st
century Earth has had an energy crisis
due to which most coal oil and natural
gas reserves are nearly gone
consequently the primary energy source
has shifted to helium-3 a resource
abundant on the moon in order to extract
this alternative fuel lunar Industries
has built serang station a facility on
The Far Side of the Moon the scene then
cuts to the sering mining base situated
on the lunar surface this facility
operates with high levels of automation
requiring only a single human to
maintain operations as a part of his job
the employee puts on a spacesuit and
goes outside where he drives a Land
Rover over to a helium-3 Harvester he
extracts the helium-3 in canisters and
then sends them back to Earth the
employee's name is Sam Bell who is
assigned for this job with a three-year
working contract is almost at the end of
his contract period because he has to
stay for Just 2 two weeks before
returning back to Earth chronic
communication problems such as a jammed
satellite have disabled his live feed
from Earth as a result it has limited
him to occasional recorded messages from
his wife Tess who was pregnant with
their daughter Eve when he left we see
how lonely Samus when he continually
talks to himself his only companion is
an advanced AI robot named Gertie who
assists him with the base's Automation
and provides emotional support
regardless the overall tone is an
unsettling one and it's not helped by
the fact that Gertie is voiced by Kevin
Spacey in the next scene Sam cleans
himself up he takes a shower dad ass and
then Gertie gives him a haircut during
which she asks him if everything is okay
he claims that he has been noticing
Sam's unusual behavior lately probably
due to loneliness and depression Sam
brushes off his concern and asks when
they will fix the lunar satellite so
that he can talk with his family again
in response Gertie tells him that the
company places a low priority on this
issue even though he has only two weeks
left in his contract he believes that
the repair is crucial because the next
man coming to take his place will have a
hard time without live communication
with Earth apart from this Sam is
starting to have headaches more often so
he asks Gertie to give him some pills on
the next day Sam receives a video
message from his wife prompting him to
play it instantly in the message Tess
says that she knows that he is feeling
very lonely on the moon's surface but
she is proud of what he is doing she
also shows their daughter Eve in the
video which cheers up Sam's mood before
ending the video Tess expresses her love
for him we then see Sam spending his
free time by engaging in various
activities crafting a miniature replica
of his hometown watering the greenhouse
plants and watching old television
programs later while fetching a glass of
hot water Sam experiences a
hallucination of a woman seated in his
chair this distracting causing his hands
to get burned by the hot water following
this Gertie applies the medical bandage
to his hand and asks what happened
however Sam chooses to hide the truth
and pretends that he got distracted
while watching TV the following morning
Sam wakes up and proceeds to carry out
his daily routine while running on a
treadmill he experiences some chest
pains but doesn't pay much attention to
them after breakfast Sam Don's spacesuit
and gets on the Rover to go extract more
helium-3 while driving Sam again has a
vision of the same woman causing his
Rover to crash into the Harvester
sensing the rapid loss of cabin air from
the crash he puts on his helmet but
still Falls unconscious a while later
Sam awakens in the base infirmary with
no memory of the accident Gertie has
been monitoring his health and asks Sam
to take some more rest sometime later
Sam overhears Gertie having what appears
to be a live chat with lunar Industries
management as a result he tries to head
towards the control room only to
discover that he is too weak to
despite this he proceeds and asks Gertie
about whom he's talking to in response
the robot replies that he was just
recording a message the next day Sam
gets up in a healthier State and walks
around the base a few moments later he
receives a message from the lunar
Industries stating that they'll be
sending a rescue team to fix the
Harvester and will be sending Sam home
instead of waiting inside the moon base
Sam claims that he can fix the Harvester
himself however Gertie doesn't allow him
to because he has been given strict
orders to keep Sam inside the base until
the rescue team arrives this arouses
suspicion in Sam's mind prompting him to
devise a plan to go out he opens a vent
and cuts one of its tubes causing gas to
spray out and he portrays this as a
grave issue using this ruse he convinces
Gertie to allow him to exit the base
following this Sam gets into another
Rover and travels to the earlier Rover
crash he opens the hatch and gets inside
only to discover a body there upon
closer examination he has taken aback to
see that the body looks just like him
Sam transports the double back to base
and tends to his injuries he turns to
Gertie seeking answers about the man's
identity and the unfolding situation in
response the robot shockingly reveals
that this man is also Sam Bell a short
while later the injured Sam regains
Consciousness only to find the fresh Sam
within the room he tries to inquire
about it to Gertie but the robot has him
rest later on the injured Sam gets out
of bed and notices another Sam skipping
the injured one tries to talk to the new
Sam he expresses his gratitude for
saving his life and extends for a
handshake but the new Sam disregards him
afterwards the two Sams get into a
heated argument and a physical
altercation regarding who is real and
who is a clone later the older Sam goes
to talk to Gertie and asks him if he is
really a clone Gertie finally reveals
that both Sams are in fact clowns he
further discloses that there was no
actual crash when the new Sam awakened
as it is a standard procedure for all
new clowns it turns out that after every
three-year contract expires a new Sam is
awakened in the infirmary moreover the
memories of Tess and Eve are simply
implanted to the clone from the original
Sam Bell the older Sam is overwhelmed by
this Revelation breaking down
emotionally Gertie tries to comfort him
but he only walks away in Silence with
only 11 hours remaining until the rescue
team's arrival the new Sam apologizes to
the old one for hurting him earlier
however the old Sam plays music loudly
in order to ignore him and troll him the
new Sam abruptly stops the music and
claims that when he woke up he overheard
Gertie having a live conversation with
lunar Industries he points out that the
communication satellite is not jammed
suggesting that lunar headquarters is
intentionally blocking their signal from
outside the moon base and preventing
their contact with Earth following this
the two sims get suited up and drive The
Rovers outside to search the area upon
going beyond the facility's perimeter
they split up to individually
investigate any unusual elements in
their surroundings they each come across
different communication substations
which have been interfering with the
live feed from Earth before long the old
Sam drops to his knees and vomits blood
in his helmet he returns back to the
base as he isn't feeling well enough to
continue Upon returning he vomits more
blood and also finds that he has lost a
tooth while the new sim continues with
the further investigation the old Sam
goes to the main computer of the bass he
proceeds to access his database when his
password fails Gertie assists him in
entering the correct credentials this
grants him access to archived recordings
from previous clones revealing a
disturbing pattern it seems that at the
end of each contract the Clone gets
increasingly sick eventually they are
placed inside a chamber where they they
are informed about entering cryogenic
sleep before their return to Earth
sensing something amiss the old Sam goes
to the room and checks on the cryogenic
Pod he finds a hollow space under the
floor and starts cutting his way in by
that time the new Sam comes back to the
base having found more towers outside
the perimeter the old Sam shows him the
secret passageway leading to the
basement the two of them then climbed
downstairs only to discover hundreds of
hibernating clones this makes them
realize that the lunar Industries is
unethically using clones of the original
sambal to avoid the cost of training and
transporting new astronauts they are
also deliberately jamming the live feed
in order to prevent the clones from
contacting Earth the Clones who believe
that they are entering hibernation at
the end of their contract just before
their final return to Earth are in fact
incinerated after this the older Sam
takes a mini computer and drives outside
in the Rover upon passing the
interference radio
tries to video call Tess on earth a
young girl answers the call and tells
him that Tess passed away years ago when
he asks about her identity the young
girl introduces herself as Eve salmon
Tess's daughter Samus profoundly shaken
to learn that his daughter is now 15
years old Eve then calls out to her dad
who is probably the original Sam Bell
when the older Sam clone hears this he
hangs up in a panic the incident causes
the old clone to break down and he sobs
expressing his wish to go home after
calming down he returns to the base and
begins displaying the same symptoms as
previous clouds as their health started
to deteriorate seeing this the new Sam
talks him into bed in the next scene the
two Sams realize that the incoming
rescue team will kill them both if they
are found together the new Sam convinces
Gertie to wake another clone he plans to
kill the awakened clown and place it in
the crashed Rover he will then send the
older Sam Earth in one of the helium-3
transporting containers meanwhile he
himself decides to act like he doesn't
know anything and pretend that he has
been inside the base the entire time
later on the older Sam wakes up and
discovers an unconscious clone in the
infirmary upon asking what's going on
the new Sam Reveals His plan to him the
older Sam expresses reluctance as they
can't kill anyone he also knows that he
will not live much longer so he makes a
change in the plan He suggests that he
be placed back into the crashed Rover to
die so that lunar Industries will not
suspect anything in the meantime he asks
the new Sam to return back to Earth
leaving the awakened clone in the moon
base with only a couple of hours
remaining before the rescue team's
arrival the two Sams Dawn their suits
and go out to the crashed Rover they
share a moments of their memories and
reminisce about how they met Tess even
though neither of them have actually met
her shortly thereafter the older Sam
falls asleep and the new carries him
back to the crashed Rover they bit each
other farewell and the new Sam heads
back with tears in his eyes back at the
moon base the new Sam makes preparations
to leave in a helium-3 container during
this Gertie points out that the plan
won't work because he has recorded
everything from the moment he woke up in
the infirmary this recording can
potentially expose the interactions
between the two clones and unveil their
plan to lunar Industries due to this the
robot advises the new Sam to erase his
own memory before leaving the new Sam
thanks Gertie and says goodbye before
rebooting him minutes before the rescue
team lands the new Sam remembers
something he hurriedly goes back to the
control room and reprograms a harvester
to crash and wreck the jamming antenna
thereby enabling live communications
with Earth additionally he brings along
a canister of helium-3 to provide him
with funds once he reaches Earth moments
before the Rescue Unit arrives he enters
the container and flies off the older
Sam remains conscious long enough to
watch the new Sam depart the rescue team
is fooled after finding both the newly
awakened clone in the infirmary and the
lifeless body of the older Sam inside
the crashed Rover in the final scene we
hear the news reports that describe
Sam's testimony regarding lunar
Industries unethical activities and how
they've sparked a major controversy and
as a consequence their stock has
plummeted significantly subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching